[Music]
what we are witnessing here is the
return of titans
[Music]
how many these things are there 17 and
captain that messed up
[Music]
mother Rodin Ghidorah
they're moving like a pack they're
hunting they all respond directly to an
alpha
we stop this Ghidorah we stop them all
is there another creature that might
stand a chance against him
[Music]
our planet will perish
so will we
[Applause]
yes we set Godzilla free
oh yeah sure let's bring him in for a
beer no this time we join the fight
run
[Music]
mrs. Godzilla's well we just live in it
damn right
personally it was really important to
make it Godzilla film that lives up to
the legacy that inspired it growing up I
would take my pet box turtle and let him
Stampede through my place that's in
front of my old camcorder like that was
literally my first attempt at making a
movie and so here we are decades later
and doing the same thing on a much
bigger scale
it's literally a dream come true
what we are witnessing here is the
return of an ancient and forgotten super
species mafra Rodin King Ghidorah and
Godzilla it was a really great all-star
team of these monsters mom the Masters I
was already in love with Mothra before
we started the movie and then as it
progressed I only fell in love with her
more my favorite will always be Mothra I
think she's just things spiritual she's
the creature that best represents a
chance for establishing a relationship
between human beings and the Titans my
girls he's the boss can't you aim for
this one
oh then the five demon that's comforting
well we've got Rodin which is another
hellish type of force mo Dan comes out
of this huge volcano row damn is one of
my all-time favorites especially because
he could fly and that he could cause
vast amounts of destruction without ever
really trying
[ __ ]
King Ghidorah he is Godzilla's nemesis I
like to say that he is the Joker to
Godzilla Batman Ghidorah for me was the
scariest one of all of them he is
literally a massive hurricane so
Godzilla's surrounded by all these other
newly risen Titans and you're not quite
sure what's gonna happen
long live the king
[Music]
it's a variable cacophony of crazy-ass
monsters
[Music]
Godzilla is my hero he's a monster made
of nightmares he's an icon
what is not to love about an
fire-breathing megawatt monster who
makes us feel all too human it doesn't
get bigger than Godzilla
[Music]
[Music]
the time has come
don't call it don't call it
Chidori don't call it catchy name for
this planet will perish Godzilla trait
so this plan is what you would call a
long shot
well let's get started
[Music]
the king
that's messed up
this is guys in his world
[Music]
rated pg-13 experience at an IMAX may
31st
hello
there's anyone there
I'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
senators we believe that these Titans
are just the tip of the iceberg which of
these Titans are here to protect us and
[Music]
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his you're sure he's
gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
arrival alpha to go
you gotta be kidding
[Music]
[Music]
and what's with the light show soon an
accommodation display Cazares very
intimidated
we open Pandora's box and there's no
closing it now
[Music]
the king
guardzilla our world is changing the
mass extinction we feared has already
begun and we are the cause we are the
infection
[Music]
but like all living organisms the earth
unleashed a fever to fight this
infection its original and rightful
rulers the Titans for thousands of years
these creatures have remained in hiding
around the world and unless all the
Titans are found our planet will perish
and so will we
they are the only guarantee that life
will carry on
[Music]
[Music]
you are on your goddamn minds I am sorry
but this is the only way
[Applause]
[Music]
long live the king
[Music]
go then
j'adore oh my oh my
they're everywhere ice comforting
our planet will perish
and so a week
unless Godzilla free
this time we join him
that's messed up get these on our side
[Music]
here we go
listen Godzilla's world you just live in
it damn right
you